wouldn't it be great
to have mike myers on your podcast
because then dana and mike
could work out whatever it is that's
going on between the two of them and
that was an hour therapy session yeah an
hour
dana would you invite mike myers on your
new podcast i swear to tell the whole
truth the only truth uh so help me god
god save us all
would you have him on of course what
oh wait yeah we already did we we've
come full circle
since i talked to you last we've become
very very close friends
oh really
we just have too much history we have an
unbelievable amount of stuff in common
we're not unique in this way obsessed by
the beatles is both his parents
are liver puddling grew up in liverpool
obsessed by world war ii
and then we had so much shared history
together uh riding the rocket of wayne's
world and really the first time we had
extra money the first time we we signed
autographs so there's too many firsts
and you know i'm just mature now the
only good thing about getting old is you
just sort of
you get a little more wisdom you get a
little more perspective and you you
practice forgiveness for others and for
yourself did this come about as a result
of the super bowl commercial that the
two of you did together in other words
it brought you into the same room and
into the same world and then there was a
reconciliation yeah well we got closer
during that whole process yeah
definitely and started talking more and
just it's very nice to have such a a
long friendship with someone and
everyone knows what we're talking about
and going back to our podcast what we do
have is that we're cast members and
there's a shorthand to that you know
so it gets
inside it's a it's emotional you know
this far away from snl it never gets out
from under your skin to quote frank
sinatra so i you it it can be kind of
emotional thinking about it really i
just feel like i came to know him in a
much better way as we've been really
really talking a lot these last couple
years and kind of put him in context
understand him and also just really
appreciate him as you look
later on
you know everyone has a ten-year-old boy
inside them
or girl and that little person gets very
jealous of the shiny new toy and very
envious and john lovitz and i would
always make a joke out of our
competition you know because the whole
show's a competition a game of thrones
and yet it's your really good friends
and you want to play fair but mike and i
became a comedy team by accident
we were in a sketch it became a movie
and what does
garth do what does wayne do so there was
conflict over how that was going to come
together but we were just riding that
rocket it wasn't personal and mike uh
has said that the reason he put you in
his wayne's world sketch was because
he knew the sketch would get on the air
if he got one of the strongest players
from the show to be in it with him yeah
and you know as friends in these last
few years and it's been a while you know
you put down all your weapons and you're
just very vulnerable and very honest
it's a great way to be with someone and
the competition goes
totally away
it's more like and and even at the time
being part of a team because i came in
as a stand-up so did david but i got a
kick out of later on just really working
with phil and he's killing in the johnny
carson sketch or with kevin neil and i
and hans and franz and mike and i you
know we were like little rock stars for
a while you know and i did love looking
i had a guy
who was always there always had
something to come back with and always
was great so a lot of appreciation with
this perspective